♪ ♪
>> Sean: TONIGHT,
GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT FILED A
LAWSUIT AGAINST PALM BEACH AND
BROWARD COUNTIES FOR VIOLATING
REGARDING VOTING NUMBERS, THIS
COMES AS A RECOUNT LOOMS OVER
HIS RACE FOR THE U.S. SENATE.
JOINING US RIGHT ON, THE MAN
HIMSELF, GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT.
GOVERNOR, I'M LOOKING AT THESE
NUMBERS APPEARED ON ELECTION
DAY, YOU WERE UP 37,000 VOTES.
WHAT IS THE NUMBER NOW?
>> NOW IT IS DOWN TO 15,000
VOTES.
SO IT IS CLEAR WE HAVE SOME
LEFT-WING ACTIVISTS, WE HAVE
SOME DEMOCRATIC -- D.C. LAWYERS
COMING DOWN HERE FOR ONE
PURPOSE, TO STEAL THIS ELECTION.
>> Sean: GOVERNOR, I LOOKED AT
THE NUMBERS, YOU WERE TOLD FIVE
DIFFERENT NUMBERS, FLORIDA LAW
SAYS THAT ALL ABSENTEE EARLY
VOTING NUMBERS MUST BE REPORTED
WITHIN 30 MINUTES OF THE POLLS
CLOSE IN, CORRECT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: IN THOSE NUMBERS --
>> Sean: SEAN, THEY FOUND A
78,000 NEW VOTES SINCE ELECTION
DAY, TWO DAYS AGO, IN
BROWARD COUNTY, AND 15,000 MORE
VOTES IN PALM BEACH.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY MORE
VOTES THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
COME UP WITH, BUT IT SURE
APPEARS THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
FIND AS MANY VOTES AS I CAN TAKE
TO WIN THE ELECTION.
SO I HAVE ASKED THE FLORIDA
DEPARTMENT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
DO AN INVESTIGATION, WE FILED A
LAWSUIT, WE ARE GOING TO FIGHT
THIS AND WE ARE GOING TO WIN.
>> Sean: IN 2016, HER OFFICE
POSTED RESULTS AND A HALF HOUR
BEFORE THE POLLS CLOSE, THAT IS
AN ELECTION VIOLATION LAW,
BROKEN.
SHE WAS SUED FOR LEAVING
AMENDMENTS OFF THE BALLOT, SHE
ALSO, IN THE CASE OF DEBBIE
WASSERMAN SCHULTZ, WHY IS THIS
PERSON EVEN WORKING THERE?
>> WHAT I HAVE DONE, I HAVE
ASKED THE DEPARTMENT OF
INVESTIGATION -- WE HAVE
EXAMPLES -- THE PALM BEACH
SUPERVISOR WON'T ALLOW NORMAL
PARTY OFFICIALS THAT ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE REVIEWING
BALLOTS, THEY ARE NOT ALLOWING
THEM TO DO IT PROPERLY, THAT IS
A VIOLATION OF THE LAW.
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO REPORT THESE
RESULTS, THEY ARE NOT.
BUT HOW DID THEY COME UP WITH
70,000 MORE VOTES?
JUST IN BROWARD, 15,000 AND
PALM BEACH BEAR NO OTHER
COUNTIES HAVE THESE PROBLEMS BUT
WE HAD A HORRIBLE HURRICANE IN
THE PANHANDLE, IT DIDN'T HAPPEN
THERE.
THE LAWYERS CAME DOWN AND
SAID -- THEY ARE HERE TO WIN THE
ELECTION, NOT HERE TO SAY, I
WANT TO FIND OUT WHAT THE
RESULTS I MAKE SURE IT IS A FAIR
RESULT.
THEY'RE DOWN HERE FOR ONE
REASON, AND THEY SAID THAT, TO
ENACT THE ELECTION CODE
>> Sean: 27 DAYS AGO, THE
PANHANDLE WAS SMASHED WITH ONE
OF THE WORST HURRICANES WE HAVE
SEEN.
THEY GOT THEIR VOTES IN ON TIME
AND THEY ENDED UP DOING THIS.
I CANNOT -- TO ME, THIS IS THE
SINGLE BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER IN
AN ELECTION I HAVE SEEN, AND
THEY HAVE MARK LES, THE GUY AT
THE HEART OF THE WHOLE
FUSION GPS, CLINTON BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR DOSSIER, LEADING THE
WAY.
>> YEP.
HE IS DOWN HERE FOR ONE PURPOSE,
TO STEAL THIS ELECTION.
HE SAID HE IS DOWN HERE TO WIN
THIS ELECTION.
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT ANYTHING ELS
ELSE.
WE WON -- I'M GOING TO BE THE
U.S. SENATE ARE, I'M GOING TO
FIGHT THIS ALL THE WAY.
WE ARE GOING TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN COME WE'RE LOOKING AT EVERY
LEGAL REMEDY WE CAN EXERCISE, WE
ARE GOING TO FIGHT THIS AND WE
ARE GOING TO WIN THIS.
>> Sean: EVERY OTHER COUNTY
EXCEPT BROWARD AND PALM BEACH
DID IT THE RIGHT WAY.
EVERY OTHER COUNTY, AND THEY
HAVE DONE THIS BEFORE.
WHY DOES SHE STILL HAVE A JOB?
>> SHE IS ELECTED IN THESE
COUNTIES.
THINK ABOUT IT, SOME OF THESE
OTHER SUPERVISORS THEY DID IT
THE RIGHT WAY OUR DEMOCRATS,
ALSO.
EVERY OTHER COUNTY, REPUBLICAN
OR DEMOCRAT, THERE WAS A
SUPERVISOR'S DATE OF THE RIGHT
WAY.
THESE TWO DIDN'T, THEY VIOLATED
THE LAW.
I HAVE ASKED THE DEPARTMENT OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DO AN
INVESTIGATION, AND WE HAVE
ALREADY FILED A LAWSUIT, WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE SURE WE WIN THIS.
I WON THIS ELECTION FOR THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE, THERE WILL
IS NOT GOING TO BE THWARTED.
>> Sean: I'M NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS IN MY LIFE.
IT IS OBVIOUSLY CORRUPT,
OBVIOUSLY LAWS WERE BROKEN,
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE SHENANIGANS
HERE, I BELIEVE YOU AND
SENATOR RUBIO ARE 100% CORRECT,
WE WILL FOLLOW THIS EVERYTHING
WILL SECOND OF EVERY DAY NOW.
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE OF FLORIDA
DESERVE THEIR JUST VOTE, WHICH
THEY GOT, AND YOU WON THIS RACE
HAS DOWN, THIS IS A DISGRACE
THAT THEY GET TO DO THIS.
ELECTION AND, ELECTION OUT.
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO GO TO JAIL
HERE.
IF THIS KEEPS HAPPENING, YOU
KEEP VIOLATING THE LAW, YOU
DON'T RESPOND, EVERY OTHER
COUNTY RESPONSE, THEN YOU CHANGE